قبل أيام قليلة فقط ، أعلن أم مايك بومبيو
وزير الخارجية
أه أن لديهم حكومة الولايات المتحدة
قد وجدت
دليلًا على أن إيران كانت تشارك في
تصعيد
الهجمات الإلكترونية ضد الولايات المتحدة ،
وهذا ادعاء
أكدته أيضًا Microsoft جزئيًا
والذي  حددت جهات فاعلة إيرانية معينة
برعاية الحكومة على ما يبدو
لماذا
تصعد إيران الحرب السيبرانية ضد
الولايات المتحدة
، أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، كانت الولايات المتحدة هي
التي اعترفت بالانخراط في
حرب إلكترونية ضد
إيران إلى درجة
تدمير
الهياكل النووية الحساسة للغاية  يمكن أن
يكون لذلك تداعيات
على موت مئات الآلاف
من الأشخاص
إذا لم تصدقني فقط شاهد
صفر يوم آه
لذلك أعني أنه كانت هناك مقالات مكتوبة
،
هل كان هناك فيلم وثائقي تم إنتاجه في
الولايات المتحدة حول تلك المحاولات
تلك
اعتراف رسمي من الحكومة الأمريكية
بوجود مزاعم بأن إيران
متورطة فيها
في محاولة
للتسلل إلى النظام الانتخابي الأمريكي أعني
هذا هراء بالنسبة لنا
لا يهم من يذهب إلى البيت الأبيض
أه إذا كان
يعني إذا كان له مصلحة في
فوز مرشح أو
ذاك فهذه الحجة يمكن أن تقام  لكن يبدو
أن الرئيس ترامب يستغل كل
فرصة
للتساؤل بشكل أساسي
عن نتائج الانتخابات الأمريكية التي هي
أه شيء
من الأخبار بالنسبة لنا جميعًا
لرئيس يشكك
في انتخاب بلاده ،
فأنت لا تهتم حقًا بما إذا كان
لا يفوز ترامب أو بايدن على الإطلاق ، فهذا ليس من شأننا
بالنسبة لنا سلوك الحكومة الأمريكية
مهم
بالنسبة لنا ، ليس من المهم من يجلس في
البيت الأبيض
كحكومة أجنبية لا يمكننا الاعتماد
على شيء لا نتحكم فيه
لاحقًا في الجلسة  تلقى وزير الخارجية
أسئلة من
آخرين سألها الصحفي والمحلل في سي إن إن
كيم دوزير عن مقتل الجنرال الإيراني قاسم سليماني في
يناير / كانون الثاني ،
إليكم ما قاله وزير الخارجية الإيراني
في المندوب.
وبقدر ما يتعلق الأمر بالجنرال سليمان ،
فقد ارتكبت الولايات المتحدة
خطأً فادحًا
باغتيال
بطريقة إرهابية واضحة شخصًا كان العدو
الأول لجنرال تنظيم الدولة ، متأكدًا من أن المال يحظى بالتبجيل
ليس فقط في إيران ولكن في أماكن أخرى
أيضًا كانت المشكلة المعرفية هي ذلك الوزير.
بومبيو ليلة اغتيال
الجنرال سوريماني
وضع على تويتر
مقطعًا لأناس يرقصون في العراق يظهرون أن
أهل العراق كانوا
يحتفلون بوفاة السليماني
ورأينا في
صباح اليوم التالي أن عشرات الآلاف
من مئات الآلاف من العراقيين
جاءوا إلى العراق.  شوارع مدن عراقية مختلفة
حزنًا
على مقتل سورياماني ، لذا فإن لدى سليماني
الكثير من الناس الذين يسعون للانتقام
أه لقتله ،
هل يمكنني فقط متابعة أه جافا هل أستخدم
أولئك الذين يقولون إن
الحكومة الإيرانية لا تزال
تفكر في احتمال حدوث نوع ما
الانتقام أم أغلقت الكتب
على أن
لا الكتب ليست مغلقة الرئيس
ترامب
أمر باغتيال بطل قومي
لإيران وبطل للمنطقة
لذا الكتب ليست مغلقة
فأنا لست في مجال
التهديد لكن الكتاب لم يغلق.